era poco probable que boris johnson
perdiera en esta ocasión pero recordemos
que no necesariamente en la pesadilla
que ha significado para él el momento
político más complejo para el primer
ministro británico haya sido superado y
todavía está la posibilidad de que se
vaya de dawn instruir porque el
parlamento británico adelantar a una
investigación para esclarecer si mintió
deliberadamente sobre el escándalo del
partido gate y recordemos que por los
antecedentes históricos del partido
conservador un primer ministro que es
sometido a una moción de confianza no
necesariamente tiene un período
adicional mucho más largo el último
antecedente que tenemos es el de theresa
may a quién boris johnson reemplazó ella
se sometió a una moción de confianza en
el 2018 y cinco meses después renunció
además tendremos que analizar las cifras
con mucho detalle pero no necesariamente
si el primer ministro sobrevive en esta
ocasión continúa con poder recordemos el
liderazgo la autoridad de boris johnson
ha estado basta bastante golpeada
analizaremos también por supuesto esas
cifras que nos pueden indicar si boris
johnson tiene el suficiente margen de
maniobra para poder el liderar con
bastante suficiencia el gobierno porque
como digo
necesariamente ésta sigue siendo el
primer ministro pero no necesariamente
tiene poder tendremos que revisar
cuántos rebeldes votaron en su contra y
eso significa que el primer ministro no
podría tener necesariamente la maniobra
la gobernabilidad que necesita para
seguir liderando el país pero lo primero
la noticia a esta hora es que boris
johnson ha sobrevivido a esa moción de
confianza que se esperaba que se diera
hace varios meses pero aclaro esto no
significa que boris johnson vaya a ser
primer ministro por mucho más tiempo o
se vaya a cambiar la página se hable de
otros asuntos como él quiere porque esto
sigue el party que es un escándalo que
lo va a perseguir seguramente durante
toda su carrera durante toda su vida
porque pese a que los conservadores han
votado por mantenerlo en él la realidad
es que el público en general quisiera
que boris johnson fuera removido de su
cargo el telegraph que es un periódico
muy pro gobierno ha revelado una
encuesta hecha el 1º de junio que dice
que el 63% de la población quisiera que
boris johnson fuera removido así que eso
nos muestra mucho el ánimo de la
situación esta moción de confianza fue
promovida hoy se supo que esta mañana
que las 54 cartas que se necesitaban
para promover esta moción de confianza
había sido llegado hace ese número
necesario porque el fin de semana
durante las celebraciones del jubileo de
la reina isabel segunda el primer
ministro fue abucheado en todos los
eventos a los que participó lo que nos
dice cuál es el ánimo de la población en
este momento